I think that when I heard the
description that that that ho sha Shan
was making a martial arts film I didn't
immediately think but of course and it
is unlike any martial arts film I think
I think that you will ever see I'm
curious like what attracted you to want
to make that was it did you love martial
arts films as a kid did you like the
historic period that it's in did you
want a chance to do action scenes I'm
curious what led you to want to make
that film Jesus umpire champion servant
of yourself me Tom sure can film - which
I shall show how he can top him couldn't
kind of him - it's you know can you
phenomena and you see you Tom Waddell
sue soil that is a power change a she's
a female participant this man says she
hates when side
technically I sent some college age in
the old times even in some cow
I see a tower chain so it her weapon
fire never vs - potato so you were
people wanting white on the weights on
just how cyka cyka has done - and the
pinch energy sea urchins under the sea
on and so on that they wish you
impossible for me or what ride it to me
yeah I can tell you that I've always
growing up I love martial art novels
which all novels I love martial art
movies and I watch a lot of Japanese
samurai films which were my favorite I
love Japanese samurai films and what was
interesting me what is interesting to me
about these samurai films or the
Japanese Way of making action
is that the sort of martial arts so to
speak that they still practice in the
film these things actually exists they
are still around
they're concrete whereas in China or in
the Chinese tradition the kind of
martial arts is seeing movies they
nowadays they've sort of evolved into a
form of dance almost it's not quite
realistic or not the way that used to be
so for me I wanted to do something that
maybe would not be as fanciful or as
colorful flamboyant as that and that's
the reason why the assassin the
character all she has is a short blade a
knife
I wanted something very kind of simple
and peered out and you shot this with
200 watts dying you will numb by dancing
ah it's even last this time director who
thought I was gonna use 200 watts but
against that Chantal you only consulted
them even smaller why Bob avenge my only
one them
it was a mostly natural light actually
was - Doyle and shreya why Managua woo
you won't be a target don't sir Kader
[ __ ] shirt oh that's part of the tandem
toys in Rwanda truly to my main ting
ting - man but it's true that there were
shots in the interior scenes I would use
big wise 18k or some of these very big
lies that would be outside but not very
many just one or two Bob wooden door has
a bead
yeah I'm by what solid there you want
them maturity at a time it was it was we
used the light bulbs or at lights that
were less than like 200 watts and a new
shot 135 and then it's transferred to
digital skin I read somewhere that you
didn't completely love the the scan is
that is that true it's true it's true -
oh Jesus varta come to the UM post are
saying for me so you see our chiidren it
attends to the Commission can the from
yeah one thing one emphasized is that
even these interior things that we shot
we actually build the sets outside so
they would be exposed to direct sunlight
so because we wanted that kind of lie
and we want a natural wind so even
though you see these things that they
take place indoor but they were actually
shot outside and the set was built
outside no I mean that it is
astonishingly beautiful film I mean even
in the transfer you don't like or the
scan that you don't like it's an
extraordinary beautiful film